right welcome back so hold on to your
seats my friends meghan markle's in the
headlines for stretching the truth again
also tonight on the show the pope is
catholic and bears do defecate in the
woods from where it's pumped directly
onto britain's beaches
yes meg's at it again she's regaled the
listener to her new podcast with the
terrifying story of how son archie
narrowly escaped a fire in his bedroom
on a royal tour of south africa
the heater
in the nursery caught on fire everyone's
in tears everyone's shaken
and what did we have to do
go out and do another official
engagement
despite being shaken and in tears she
and harry bravely and i mean bravely
resumed their duties but it turns out
that archie wasn't even in the room when
it happened and royal sources today told
the press that they don't even recall
any fire at all merely an overheating
heater you try saying that now this
isn't the first time megan's face claims
that the truth isn't necessarily the
truth our investigative units and a top
team of data journalists have produced
this forensic visualization of megan's
fibs she famously told oprah she married
prince harry intimately and in secret
days before their televised bash in
windsor the archbishop canterbury said
oh no she didn't megan claims the royal
family took away her passport leaving
her a princess trapped in a tower but
investigation by her own the son found
she took at least 13 foreign holidays
during the period in which she was
apparently grounded megan also claimed a
member of the royal household expressed
concerns about the i can't do this the
color of her unborn child's skin while
she was pregnant but she's never been
able to say who it was and she says she
barely knew anything about the royal
family the nose can't get any bigger
before she met harry friends have said
she was a royal fanatic who visited bp
as a child and wanted to be diana 2.0
there you go my friends lies damn lies
and the dusting of sussex or as the
queen yourself put it recollections may
vary joining me now is robert johnson
royal editor at the evening standard of
tonight's panel esther craig here i
can't wait for my labour adviser my good
friend richard powersaid welcome people
hello thank you um
uh let's start with you robert yeah um
why is this woman such a divisive
character why does she generate
the column inches the comments i mean
she seems to annoy
slash
excel in people's brains so much why
i mean i think that the oprah winfrey
interview didn't help i mean that was
pretty awful as we went through the
pinocchio stories there but uh i think
it's it's i was talking about the guys
earlier if we all landed in l.a tomorrow
i think there would be a difference in
the way things
be fair to her the way we address issues
but yeah as i say i was in south africa
on that okay the the the foreign office
of issued a statement saying that all
our residencies meet the
requirements health and safety
requirements um tried contacted all the
three people that were the aides there
today and none of them would answer any
questions because unlike this program i
think that the palace is somewhat
censored when it comes to meghan markle
they're a bit scared of her they're a
bit scared of what they should say about
her as well because the reactions
um but i was there i i don't recall any
fire engines i mean we didn't get the
story obviously we were pretty rubbish a
job but there were no stories and the
whole of the south african press didn't
cover this incident there were no fire
engines called to the residents you know
we have to ask questions about that but
she's saying that you know it was a
smoke was in the room
i tell you what my issue is richard just
to bring you in a sec because i know
what my mate is
i was asking the crew earlier one of the
cameras said
i sort of feel she gets bad press but my
argument would be
she comes across as lacking in ingenuous
she why wasn't this said at the time it
all seems to be this orchestrated
campaign to to gain
popularity which i sort of want to tell
her she's never going to regain you've
taken 118 million
be quiet i mean it seems to me that that
you could say something quite similar
with quite a lot of different members of
the royal family yeah um look i i think
uh
she's not got very many very interesting
things to say i feel quite sorry for her
because i think she's been obsessively
uh kind of slightly creepily obsessed
over by the british media do you think
she thought do you think she came from
california that different lifestyle and
thought i'm going to change the world
i'm going to modernize the monarchy i'm
going to save harry from the misery that
he's going through i'm going to be this
beacon of light and very quickly people
went well i'm not buying what you're
saying love i mean if she thought that
then she was incredibly naive but she
might quite reasonably have thought that
you know there's one prince who's going
to become head of state who thinks it's
fine to undermine our democracy and sort
of you know what what was he doing
taking taking enormous donations from
somebody who his chief aide then makes
sure this saudi billionaire gets
citizenship and a knighthood from the
queen i mean it's really really ranked
that's what one of them's doing the
other one's friends with pedophiles and
frankly is probably not telling the
truth about it she might quite
reasonably have thought that she wasn't
going to be the most unpopular member
before that unless she had a crystal
ball she wouldn't
we can't yeah listen you have a right to
european that's what talk is all about
isn't it i mean
maybe she has a point is it not the way
esther that she does this to me it's so
i was i don't even know what the right
word is even the name of that goddamn
yes just not lacking in anything genuine
i just don't buy it but i think that's
that was her biggest frustration being
part of the royal family she couldn't
curate her image for the public that's
the problem she had because i think when
you when you she said she didn't grow up
in tabloid culture fine but there is a
way you can manipulate media in the u.s
to try and sort of pretend a certain
image but when you're part of the firm
your first sort of duty is your duty to
the firm and to the country it's not
about curating the perfect image of
yourself i completely agree that you
know there are members of the royal
family that are less palatable i've
always advocated that prince andrew
should be kept in the catacombs of paris
um that doesn't change anything that
doesn't change the fact that meghan
markle is completely unlikable and the
thing is that she can only milk two
years in the royal family for so long
what exactly does what else does she
have to say what else what else is there
to her you know torturous life as part
of the royal family there's nothing else
my point is this and i absolutely
support my old man worked for the royal
family for 41 years and he always said
and you talk about the part of the firm
he always said um that anybody passed
the queen mother and the queen has
systematically used the press for their
own ends whenever they've wanted it he
included charles danner and all of all
of the rest of them and he doesn't think
that mystique will ever return so maybe
we're being unfair to meghan markle or
maybe richard has a point that actually
if they looked at themselves
not william and kate i think but but
they're all as bad are a lot of them as
bad as each other why does she get if we
balance his viewpoint i think he's
coming from a different angle i think
the royal family do a terrific job for
this country you know why and i think
that when you see what the prince of
wales has done in terms of his you know
the amount of well and the queen and the
amount of work they do on behalf of the
government i think you know that's the
point we seem to forget is that the
foreign office has asked him to do this
what upsets a lot of people i think is
that megan was around for
two minutes really you know not long
enough she didn't give it long enough i
think she could have done a terrific job
in the commonwealth she would have given
diversity a real plus i think that
there's a lot of things that she could
have done and he just gave up on it and
i just don't this lady's story she was
forced to go out on this job i very much
doubt anyone would have thought been
unfortunately let alone her own husband
to make a go on this job if she was that
distraught about her no i mean if there
was a fire in my house there's no way i
wouldn't i wouldn't be doing this show
i'd have been at home
exactly but what what was it it wasn't
firebombing it's quite interesting what
esther says about likability i
absolutely take it but i go back to the
old man and he says that when the queen
dies and we've had this discussion
before he doesn't believe the royal
family or the monarchy will ever be the
same again now a lot of people will
disagree with that but the queen i think
will never we will never appreciate what
an amazing woman until she's no more but
but are they as bad as each other is it
her like but is it the way she goes
about stuff that's what it is i don't
think that the royal family's success
until this moment has been based upon
likability like that it's not it's hard
work and graph by the queen right
exactly and you know what i was saying
but you know i think meghan markle's uh
podcast sounds quite boring well you
know what the queen is quite boring in a
pretty impressive way right about 70
years of a life but i don't know what
i don't think the queen's boring at all
when she what she does and what she did
when we really needed her during the
pandemic when boris johnson had covered
when the prince was coming down with she
came in with that that statement which
great created a sense of calm yeah when
the when the politicians couldn't have
done that when you had boris jimmy away
and these two experts about what we
should be doing what we should be doing
showing us various graphs from school
about covered it was the queen's words
you know we will meet again and prince
is not going to be able to do that
but i think that the prince of prince of
wales will be able to draw people
together i think that what jeremy's
saying is right but he is
it's a terrifically hard working man
somebody i think yes you'll believe it
okay there are has anything illegal been
done with this donation from charity no
otherwise he'd be under investigation
with the police so that isn't the case
do you think that you think the police
would tell you do you think the police
would be investigated
of course they did of course they
weren't there they investigated prince
andrew as what we're going to say i was
going to say that i think one thing that
has
we all respect about the queen is her
sense of duty and aside from the whole
likability argument which we can go back
and forth it's the fact that meghan
markle never showed a sense of duty and
that was the biggest issue i think you
know and i i don't necessarily blame her
because celebrity culture in the us is
very different right there's no real
sort of there's no
equivalent of the royal family in the
u.s you become a celebrity you get rich
you donate money and you're god right in
the uk in the uk it's completely
different you know there's a real this
is why piers morgan's in america at the
moment
yeah absolutely but you know you have
that you have to be able to read the
room you have to have some respect for
the british public there are certain
things you just don't do and i don't
think she completely understood i think
it's really interesting because i can
see all points i i get what you're
saying richard actually about if you
look at if you point a mirror at the
rest of them actually there's a lot of
them who aren't great i think i think
you though robert have a really good
point as well she was here two minutes
people have done 70 years yes they'll
have made mistakes but it's about duty
phillip i mean look at prince
you know incredible servant to the crowd
incredible servant to the queen there's
a strengthened stay and i just think
that that just was such a he must have
been looking at this but towards the end
of his life and thinking what on earth
what a shambles what's all the you know
what's all the graphs
go on this is a grown-up country we
should have a grown-up political system
why do we have american why do we have
this fairytale nonsense this is a
constitutional monarchy and a
parliamentary embarrassing where are we
going to watch democracy do you want the
american democracy where you get biden
and trump what do you want president
boris
mps if they wanted to get rid of the
monarchy we have by the way got rid of
the monarchy once before then the mp's
now system will sort that out work out
my friends as i draw to a close how much
the american president cost the british
over the american people and how much
the monarchy brings into british coffers
but will agree to disagree meghan markle
might be in your heart you might believe
she's the greatest thing since sliced
bread or you might believe as piers
morgan once said princess pinocchio only
believes what she says herself